ولداع مسيره الاقتصاد المزدهر في المملكه
يولس مو سيدي ولي العهد حفظه الله
اهتماما وحرصا شديدا على اشراك القطاع
الخاص وتعزيز دوره في تنميه الاقتصاد
الوطني وتحقيق رؤيه السعوديه 2030
والتي تشجع على الابتكار والتنوع
الاقتصادي وتهدف الى رفع مساهمه القطاع
الخاص في الناتج المحلي الاجمالي من 40%
الى 65% بحلول عام 2030
وحيث ان دائما التنميه الوطنيه هو احد اهم
ركائز استراتيجيه صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه وضع الصندوق استراتيجيه لتنميه
وتطوير 13 قطاع استراتيجي في المملكه
حيث املنا على تطوير مبادرات حرصنا من
خلالها على وضع اليه واضحه لاشراك القطاع
الخاص كمستثمر وشريك ومورد في تلك
القطاعات
فعلى سبيل المثال في قطاع التطوير العقاري
والبنيه التحتيه قدمت شركه روشن فرص
للقطاع الخاص المحلي عبر تخصيص 30% من
اراضيها للمطورين العقاريين المساهمه في
بناء مشاريع سكنيه بافضل المعايير
وقام الصندوق بالاستثمار في العديد من
القطاعات الواعده في المملكه بهدف تطويرها
وتحويلها الى قطاعات جانبه للاستثمار بما
يتماشى مع التوجهات الاستراتيجيه في
المملكه
حيث حيث اسس
الشركه السعوديه للاستثمار لاعاده التدوير
سيرك
لاهمية قطاع اعاده التدوير ودعم تطويره
كما قام الصندوق بتاسيس شركات مختصه
بالاستثمار المشترك ودعم نمو القطاع الخاص
حيث استثمر
شركه صندوق الصناديق جدة في اكثر من 20
صندوق استثماري لدعم 350 شركه محليه
واقليميه حيث ساهمت هذا الاستثمارات الى
تعزيز نمو القطاع المنشات الصغيره
والمتوسطه
كما عمل على ادراج عدد من الشركات التابعه
له في اسواق المال السعوديه الامر الذي
ساهم في تشجيع القطاع الخاص والمستثمرين
المحليين والدوليين على المشاركه
والاستثمار في السوق المحلي
وخلال الاعوام الماضيه عملت شركه سرك مع
الجهات المعنيه لبناء بيئه استثماريه
جاذبه للاستثمارات الخاصه التي ساهمت في
تحفيز هذا القطاع والجذب العديد من رؤوس
الاموال المحليه والاجنبيه
وتهدف استراتيجيه الصندوق لاتاحه الفرص
لتوريد المنتجات والخدمات لمشاريع وشركات
الصندوق في المملكه
والمساهمه في تطوير قدرات شركات القطاع
الخاص المحليه والقيام بدراسات للطلب
المتوقع للمشاريع
بهدف ايجاد سبل شراكه مع القطاع الخاص
لدعم زياده الانتاجيه وتعزيز سلاسل
الامداد المحليه
وقد استثمر الصندوق نحو 5 مليار ريال
سعودي في اربع شركات وطنيه رائده في قطاع
المقاولات شركه نسمه وشركائه من المقاولات
وشركه السيف وشركه البوانئ القابضه وشركه
المباني
عبر زياده راس مال الشركات بهدف بناء
كيانات متينه تواكب نهضه المملكه في قطاع
الترشيد والبناء
ويستهدف الصندوق من خلال استراتيجيه ضخ ما
يصل الى واحد تريليون ريال سعودي في
المشاريع الجديده محليا
كما يستهدف زياده مساهمه الصندوق
وشركاتها التابعه في المحتوى المحلي الى
60% في نهايه 20 25
وقد اسى الصندوق الاداره العامه للتنميه
الوطنيه للاسهام في هذه الاهداف
حيث تركز الاداره على تحديد التوجهات
الاستراتيجيه للصندوق
في التنميه الاقتصاديه وقياس
وقياس الاثر الاستراتيجيه الصندوق
واستثماراته حيث عملت الاداره العامه
للتنميه الوطنيه على اطلاق مجموعه من
البرامج ومنها برنامج تنميه المحتوى
المحلي مساهمه والذي يهدف الى دعم وتطوير
القدرات المحليه للمنافسه على المستوى
الاقليمي والعالمي
وخلال هذا المنتدى سنعلن عن برامج
واتفاقيات اخرى مصممه للقطاع الخاص في
تسهيل التواصل بين الصندوق وشراكاته مع
القطاع الخاص وتفعيل مجالات الشراكه بشكل
فاعل ومستدام ومنها اطلاق منصه جديده
لمشاركه معلومات مفصله حول فرص المتاحه
للمستثمرين والموردين من القطاع الخاص
وفي الختام مؤكد حرص الصندوق على تعزيز
سبل التواصل وتطويرها بين القطاع الخاص
والصندوق وشركاته وادعوكم جميعا للاستفاده
من هذا المنتدى والمشاركه في جلسات الحوار
والاطلاع على ما يقدمه الصندوق من برامج
وفرص سيستم في تعزيز النمو الاقتصادي
وتوطين الصناعات وتحفيز الابتكار في عدد
من القطاعات الاستراتيجيه للمملكه
وتطلع الى تفعيل اوجه التعاون وتعزيز
مستوى الشراكه بين صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه والقطاع الخاص واتوجه بالشكر لكم
جميعا على حضوركم معنا اليوم
شكرا
[تصفيق]
اذا نكتفي بهذا القدر من كلمه ياسر ميان
محافظ صندوق الاستثمارات العامه السعوديه
خلال افتتاح منتدى صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه والقطاع الخاص طبعا ارميانا مشدده
على انه هناك اعلان عن اتفاقيات خاصه
بالقطاع الخاص في مؤتمر اليوم خلال هذا
المؤتمر وهذا المنتدى وايضا رساله واضحه
نتبع نشرتنا مشاهدينا ونبدا مع الملف
الملف الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه حيث اكدت
كل من القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه انها
تخوض معارك عنيفه للسيطره على وسط مدينه
بخموت في شرق اوكرانيا وفقا لقائد القوات
البريه الاوكرانيه الكسندر سيرسكي فان
وحدات هجوميه تابعه للمجموعه الروسيه
المسلحه فاجنر تهاجم من الاتجاهات عده في
محاوله للتقدم نحو احياء الوسط من جهته
قال افريني بريكوجين رئيس مجموعه فاجن انه
كلما اقترب مقاتلون مجموعه من وسط باخموت
ازدادت المعارك قسوه وكان هناك استخدام
للمدفعيه ومنذ اشهر تحولت مدينه باخمت الى
مركز للمعارك على الجبهه الشرقيه في
اوكرانيا قال الرئيس الاوكراني ان مستقبل
اوكرانيا يعتمد على نتائج المعارك في
النقاط الرئيسيه في شرق البلاد واصفا
الوضع في تلك المناطق بالصعب والمؤلمه
للغايه
ايام فقط محاربون والضغط العالمي على
روسيا سيضمنان حمايه فعاله لحريه اوكرانيا
واوروبا باسرها والعالم الحر كالعاده
تواصلت مع قاده الاستخبارات الوضع صعب
ومؤلم للغايه في الشرق يجب علينا تدمير
القوه العسكريه للعدو هناك سندبرها في
بحموتا وكمانكا وبنخريبكه وجميع الاماكن
الاخرى حيث يتم تحديد مستقبلنا الذي نناظر
من اجله
بينما يقاتل الجنود في الجبهات الشرقيه
لاوكرانيا ينقذ مسعف اللواء 93
الميكانيكيه المنفصل الارواح ويخاطرون
بحياتهم لانقاذ الجرحى من منطقه القتال
الناشطه حول بخموت وتعمل الفرقه الطبيه
على مدار الساعه وتعالج اكثر من عشره
عناصر يوميا لكن الطاقم في اوائل مارس فقد
مسعفه عشرينيه بصواريخ جراد المعاديه
[موسيقى]
افادت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه ان
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه ستفتح قضيتين
تطلان مسؤولين روسيين اثنين حيث جاءت
القضيه الاولى حول تورط روسيا في خطف
اطفال اوكرانيين اما قضيه الاخرى فكانت
حول استهداف القوات الروسيه للبنى التحتيه
المدنيه في اوكرانيا وفقا لما افادت به
الصحيفه فيما لم تؤكد المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه الادلاء باي تعليق على هذا
التقرير الصحفي الا ان المدعي العام قال
في وقت سابق ان عمليات خطف الاطفال
المشتبه بها يتم التحقيق بها وانه لا يمكن
ان يعامل الاطفال على انهم غنائم حرب وسعت
سبع فتروسيا في الامم المتحده نسخه من
مراسلات رسميه مع المانيا والدنمارك
والسويد بشان التحقيقات في تفجير خطي نور
ستريم على اعضاء مجلس الامن والجمعيه
العامه للامم المتحده وقالت البعثه
الروسيه في بيان لها ان المراسلات تؤكد ان
الدول الثلاث لم
روسيا على سعر التحقيقات مجدده مطالبتها
بشان انشائي لجنه دوليه بقياده الامم
المتحده للنظر في عمليه تخريب انابيب نور
ستريم تتسارع مشاهدينا عمليات وتدريب
القوات الاوكرانيه في عدد من البلدان
الاوروبيه كابولندا والمانيا واسبانيا
تحديدا على دبابات اثنين الالمانيه ويامل
الغرب ان تغير هذه الدبابات في مجرى
المعارك في عدد من الجبهات المشتعله في
اوكرانيا خلال الاشهر القادمه
يتدربون اثنتي عشره ساعه في اليوم لسته
ايام في الاسبوع يصارعون عدوهم الاول
الوقت يطوعون ثلاثه اشهر من التدريب
الالزامي في خمسه او ثمانيه اسابيع كحد
اقصى ويعيدون بناء جيش قادرا على استعمال
الات الحرب الحديثه فعشرون بالمئه فقط من
الجيش الاوكراني قادر على التعامل مع
الدبابات الحربيه في ساعات الصباح الاولى
يبدا الجنود الاوكراني التدريب في مركز
سان جورجو العسكري في زارا جوزا شرقيه
اسبانيا حوالي 55 جنديا يتدربون على قطع
تحاكي العمل على الدبابات الحقيقيه قبل
خروجهم الى معسكرات التدريب تتطلب دبابه
ليو بارد الواحده طاقما يتكون من اربعه
جنود لتشغيلها بالمقابل فهي تقدم مميزات
عده تجعل قرار ارسال مئات الجنود الاوكران
للتدريب في خضم الحرب قرارا مهما ويعد
مدفع دبابه ليوبارد اثنان من اهم الميزات
الموجوده فيها اذ يمتلك قدره ثبات عاليه
على الاراضي غير المستويه بسرعه 70
كيلومترا مدعوما بنظام تحكم رقمي ميزه
تفتقر لها الدبابات الاوكرانيه التي تعود
لعهد الاتحاد السوفيتي كما ان مقدمه
الدبابه مدعومه بصفائح مضاده للالغام ميزه
اخرى امام الالغام الروسيه الذكيه التي
تقفز من مكانها لاقتناس الدبابات
الاوكرانيه
يظل تحدي الاكبر هو امكانيه توظيف
التدريبات المكثفه التي تلقاها الجنود في
ميدان المعارك المشتعله الذي سيكون الحسم
في رهان الغربي على هذه الدبابات كرم
حناوي العربيه
ومن كافي ينضم الينا الصحفي محمد البابا
اهلا بك سيد محمد يعني منذ دقائق قليله
جدا ذوت سفارات الانذار هل من معلومات حول
اسبابها والوضع الان
صباح الخير يعني حتى هذه اللحظه لم تعرف
اسباب يعني صرصارات الانذار والانذار
الجوي الذي بدا يغطي جميع الاراضي
الاوكرانيه هناك احتمالين اما ان يكون
هناك ضربات صاروخيه او اطلاق مسيرات
ايرانيه الصنع من نوع شهيد باتجاه المدن
الرئيسيه الاوكرانيه ومنها العاصمه
الاوكرانيه او مجرد اقلاع طائرات ميج 31
من الاراضي البيلاروسيه يعني لن تستطيع
حتى هذه اللحظه الحصول على المعلومات لانه
يعني من حوالي دقيقتين
بكامل الاراضي الاوكرانيه ننتظر يعني
المعلومات خلال الدقائق الساعات الاخيره
محمد ماذا حملت من الجانب الاوكراني بما
يخص تطورات الوضع تحديدا بمعارك باخمت
يعني كان هناك قصف صاروخي ليله امس على
خرسون وعلى خاركوب وايضا يعني قبل حوالي
ساعتين تساقطت عده يعني مدينه ادى الى
سقوط ضحايا ليس هناك حصيله حتى هذه اللحظه
ولكن ما يتداول من تسجيلات يعني فيديو
ارسلت عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ان
هناك ضربات اصابت مباني سكنيه داخل مدينه
كلماتوس وهناك سقوط ضحايا بين قتلى وجرحا
ننتظر ايضا يعني ان هذه الحادثه قبل حوالي
ساعه من الان ننتظر من المعلومات عن سقوط
الضحايا ولكن المعارك المحترمه لا تزال في
مدينه باخمت بشكل كبير القوات الاوكرانيه
تستمر بارسال تعزيزات عسكريه ودبابات
واليات وبالامس شاهدنا ايضا يعني تسجيلات
فيديو نشرت عبر وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
عن وحدات عسكريه نقلت من غرب اوكرانيا
باتجاه يعني محور ضخمه كريمينيا
وبدا الجيش الاوكراني يكثف وحداته
القتاليه في تلك المنطقه القوات الروسيه
والقوات الاوكرانيه تشتبك بشكل عنيف تعتبر
معركه مدينه باقموطيه من اقصى المعارك
التي جرت خلال الفتره الماضيه منذ ثمانيه
اشهر تحول القوات الروسيه مجموعات ايضا
ضخت بمجموعات جديده واعلن ان مجموعه بدات
بعمليه تجنيد لتعويض الخسائر التي خسرتها
وكما قال الرئيس الاوكراني انه خلال يومين
او ثلاثه ايام الماضيه خسرت مجموعات
ما يزيد عن الف جندي روسي قتلوا داخل يعني
او في الاحياء الشرقيه لمدينه الجيش
الاوكراني ايضا اعلن انه قام بقصف مراكز
عسكريه للقوات الروسيه بالقرب بالقرب من
وهي تقع عند حدود مقاطعه لوغانست وايضا في
جنوب اوكرانيا في مقاطعه كرسون كان هناك
تبادل للقصف المدفعي في اقصى جنوب خرسون
بالقرب من البحر الاسود حيث تحاول القوات
الاوكرانيه السي على بعض الكره التي لا
تزال بالقرب من مدينه خرسي من الجهه
الجنوبيه ويعني قيل ان القوات الروسيه
بدات بسحب وحداتها من الخطوط الاماميه في
تلك المنطقه نعم شكرا جزيلا لك اذا الصحه
في محمد البابا وانطلاقا من ما يصرح به
الكريم الان بان روسيا لا تعترف بالولايه
القضائيه للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه في لها
ينضم الينا من موسكو الدبلوماسي الروسي
السابق في تسلاف ماتوزا اهلا بك يعني اذا
الكرملين لا يعترف بما يخرج عن المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه بلهاي طبعا الموضوع
مرتبط
بتقرير لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز حول فتح
قضيتين تطالان مسؤولين روسيين ما اذا لدى
الدفاعات الروسيه للرد على هذه الاتهامات
اولا في السنوات الماضي الاخيره روسيا
تعودت ان امريكا تعتبر ان محكمه
احد المناطق مثلا هي تعتبر كمحكمه دوليه
معقبه لاي انسان في العالم يستولوا عليه
يا تايلاند يا في السودان يعطي اي منطقه
اخرى ويجلب الى المحكمه النيويورك
ويعتبرون انها حق لامريكا ان
يعمل تقارير من المحكمه اقليم نيويورك
ويحولوها على محكمه الدوليه نحن الان
اعترف هذا الاسلوب اولا هذا
امريكا تحاول ان تثبته انها الدوله
الاساسيه في العالم التي تقرر وين هو الحق
وين هو غير الحق ولذلك هذا لا يعترفون ولا
يمكن
المحكمه محكمه الجايه الدوليه يعني عندما
تقرر توجيه اي اتهام يعني هي تستند طبعا
الى وقائع لماذا روسيا تقول نحن لا نعترف
بسلطتكم القضائيه لماذا لا تقدم دلائل
تثبت براءتها يعني احد الاتهامات لهؤلاء
الاشخاص احد المسؤولين الروس بتدمير
البنيه التحتيه الروسيه وذلك الجميع يمكن
ان يراه من خلال الفيديوهات والقصف الروسي
ان كان على العاصمه كياف او باقي المدن
الاوكرانيه
حرب حقيقيه استدمت الولايات المتحده
الامريكا وهو مع الروسي امريكا تاخذ هذا
المعركه بالوكاله بالوكاله الجيش
الاوكراني يزودها بسلاح بفلوس
متطوعين على زيادته خبراء العسكر يدربون
جيش اوكرانيا
جنودهم ولذلك انا لا اعتبر ان هذا
الفكره الجديه من امريكا لانه في حقيقه
هناك حرب اي طرف من طرفين امريكا اوروسيا
في هذا الحرب هو سيكون صاحب الفكره تشكيل
المحكمه
لانك ما يقول يقول عندنا من مينا ابو بكر
امريكان يعتبرون ان روسيا خسرت في هذا
الاستدامه المصلى بالعكس انا الاحظ الان
انا في
لا تصور انه حق
لقوانين دوليه هذا شيئا لا يحترم اولا
امريكا
الذي يعتبرون انهم اصحاب القرار اصحاب
المحكمه لا نحن لا
باوامر امريكيه بلا اي شاب ولذلك
اي تحرك فاغنر في بحموت وهو
مؤسسه عسكريه خاصه تعمل عسكريا في منطقه
محمود فقط جيش في شمال والجنوب ولكن في
بطن فقط مجموعه معروف ان الدول تستعين
بهكذا مؤسسات عسكريه عندما تريد ان يعني
تقوم
باختراقات عسكريه واستعمال اسلحه غير مصرح
بها دوليا يعني الشيء الذي لا تستطيع
الجيش الروسي ربما القيام به تنفذه قوات
فاجنر على كل الاحوال الكريمل الان بتصريح
لا يزال من المس تحيل نقل الصراع في
اوكرانيا الى مسار سلمي هكذا يقول كريم
للان
يقول ان يفضل الحل السياسي ومن بدايه
عمليه عسكريه خاصه في اوكرانيا
اقترحت هناك فكره حل السياسي التاقك بهذا
الحال
وزير الخارجيه اوكرانيا في اسطنبول في
ابريل 22
اتفقوا تقريبا اعترفوا
على طريقه كيف يحل المشكله ولكن من قبل
ومن قبل واشنطن بلينكن قالوا بكل بوضوح ان
اللائق امكانيه
مفاوضات والحوار السياسي مع روسيا بدون
هزيمه كامله لروسيا في حقل لذلك شو مطلوب
من روسيا من روسيا الطريقه الوحيده ان
يتقدموا ويحرروا اوكرانيا
من تلك المرتزقه وتلك الجيش الذي يعمل
بالوكاله ضد امن القومي الروسي انا شخصيا
اعتبر ان نهايه ليست مفاوضات نهايه الحرب
سيكون ده عندما تصل القوات الروسيه الى
حدود بولونيا على حدود
شمال اليوم حوالي خمسين دوله تساعد وتشارك
امريكا في الدعم العسكري والاقتصادي لجيش
اوكرانيا ولكن هذا لا يفيده
الان
ينقص الجيش الغربي قوات الغربيه
لتزويد اوكرانيا
بكميه كافيه من الصواريخ من الذخائر لا ما
بكافر انا استهلاك
هايل حوالي خمسه
الاف ذخيره يوميا يستعمل من جانب روسيا
و30 الف من جانب اوكرانيا
من موسكو الدبلوماسي الروسي السابق
تحرك لافت لقاده امريكا وبريطانيا
واستراليا اذ اعلنوا عن خطه لتزويد كاميرا
بغواصات تعمل بالطاقه النوويه في مواجهه
التحديات الصينيه المتزايده والحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا المؤيده للغرب وحضرت
الصين من ان اوكوس قد يؤدي الى اشعال
السباق تسلح واتهمت الدول الثلاث بالتسبب
بانتكاسه في جهود منع الانتشار النووي
وقالت الناطقه باسم الخارجيه الصينيه
ماونينج لصحافيين في بكينه نحوض الولايات
المتحده والمملكه المتحده واستراليا على
التخلي عن عقليه الحرب البارده
الصين تشدد على ان اتفاق اوكسو بين امريكا
واستراليا وبريطانيا سيقود نظام عدم
انتشار الاسلحه النوويه ونعبر عن اعتراضنا
الشديد عليه لانه يبين ان هذه الدول
الثلاث تغاضت عن القلق الذي عبرنا عنه
واختارت الطريق الخطا نشر اسلحه تعتمد على
اليورانيوم في المحيط الهادئ ضد
الاتفاقيات الدوليه ليس في صالح المستوى
الدولي لذلك تعرض الصين بيع غواصات
النوويه الاستراليا هذه الدول الثلاث يجب
ان تتراجع عن الترتيبات التي تهدد دولا
اخرى ويجب عليها التخلي عن هذا السلوك
الذي يهدف لاحتواء الصين
وقال وزير الدفاع الاسترالي ان اتفاقيه
شراء غواصات هجوميه تعمل بالطاقه النوويه
من الولايات المتحده ضروريه لمواجهه اكبر
حشد عسكري تقليدي في المنطقه منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه
كان هناك جهد دبلوماسي ضخم مستمر منذ شهور
وزاد بشكل خاص خلال الاسبوع الماضي بيني
وبين وزير الخارجيه ورئيس الوزراء واجرينا
اكثر من 60 مكالمه مع القاده الاقليميين
والعالميين داخل المحيط الهادئ نشاهد
النظام العالمي القائمه على القواعد يتعرض
لضغط هائل في اوروبا الشرقيه وفي المحيطين
الهندي والهادئ ونحن نشهد اكبر حشد عسكري
تقليدي شاهدناه منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه وهذا يحدث داخل منطقتنا وعلينا
الرد على ذلك
احتفل الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن مع رئيسي
وزراء بريطانيا واستراليا باتفاق اوكوس
على منصه في سانيجو وتظهر في الخلفيه
غواصه من نوع فرجينيا ستتسلى مثيلاتها
استراليا بنهايه العقد
اريد ان اكون واضحا منذ البدايه فلا يكون
هناك اللغط او سوء فهم فهذه النقطه مفصليه
الغواصات تسير بالقوه النوويه وليست مسلحه
نوويا مسيره وليست مسلحه نوويه
جدد الرئيس الامريكي كثيرا على هذه الميزه
في محاوله للتاكيد ان الولايات المتحده لا
تسعى مع استراليا الى تهديد الدول في
المحيط الهادئ خصوصا الصين
اتفاق اوكسو الذي نؤكده هنا في ساندييغو
يمثل اكبر استثمار في امكانيات استراليا
العسكريه في تاريخ بلادنا
ويشمل الاتفاق الذي اعلن عنه بدايه
التعاون بين البحريه الامريكيه
والاستراليه في مجال الغواصات المسيره على
القوات النوويه ثم تسليم استراليا ثلاث
غواصات امريكيه على ان تتعاون بريطانيا
والولايات المتحده في بناء غواصات بصناعه
استراليه
تزيد الغواصات والسفن المسيره بالطاقه
النوويه من مسافه الابحار وهذا يعني
الابتعاد عن شواطئ استراليا والاقتراب من
شواطئ الصين ومن الخطوط البحريه الصينيه
الى الشرق الاوسط من حيث يستوردون الطاقه
جاء اتفاق اوكوس على حساب فرنسا اولا لانه
استراليا تخلت عن شراء الغواصات الفرنسيه
كما يبدو الاتفاق تهيئه لمواجهه المحاولات
الصينيه للتوسع في المحيط الهادئ رئيس
وزراء بريطانيا لم يتردد في الحديث عن
المخاطر
ان في الاشهر الثمانيه عشر الماضيه تصاعدت
التحديات التي واجهناها من اجتياح روسيا
لاوكرانيا الى التصرفات الصينيه
والاضطرابات التي تسببت بها ايران وكوريا
الشماليه وكلها تهدد العالم بالمخاطر
والاضطرابات والانقسام يبدو هذا الاتفاق
على انه تاهيل واضح للقوه العسكريه
الاستراليه بدعمًا من الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا وايا كانت التبريرات فهذا
التاهيل العسكري لاستراليا يبدو موجها ضد
الصين العربيه
ينضم الينا الصحفي نادر رونج اهلا بك سيد
نادر يعني استراليا الاقرب الى الصين دخلت
على
مجموعه القوى التي تمتلك غواصات تعمل
بالطاقه النوويه وقع هذا الخبر على الصين
ورد الفعل يعني المتوقع خاصه بانه
الخارجيه الصينيه كان لها تصريحات منذ
قليل تحدثت بانه على واشنطن ولندن التخلي
عن سياسه احتواء الصين وهي ترفض بشده هذه
الصفقه
نعم صحيح اهلا ومرحبا بكم هذا
هذه الصفقه يعني
تخالف اهداف وغاره معاهده الدوليه لعدم
انتشار الاسلحه النوويه فمهما كانت الحجج
فالواقع هو ان الدول التي تمتلك الاسلحه
النوويه تقوم بالنقل المواد يعني
اليورانيوم اليه مخاصم
القابل لصناعه الاسلحه للدوله او منطقه
خاليه من الاسلحه النوويه فهذا يشكل خطرا
كبيرا في هذا المنطقه وايضا يحدد نظام
الدولي لعدم انتشار النووي وكذلك ترى
الصين ان
ان هذا الامر يخص المرجعيه المعاهده وكذلك
فعاليته ويجب على
المتعهده بهذه الامه هذا
ستار قرار او من خلال النقاش فيما بين هذه
الدول
القرار المشتركه بهذا الامر ولا يجب
ليس امر يعني يقرر الدول الثلاثه لان هذا
امر يعني
يشكل خطرا يعني كبيرا على السلام
والاستقرار في هذه المنطقه ولكن الى اين
يمكن ان تذهب الصين في رد فعلها سيد نادر
خاصه بانه الرئيس الصيني وصف هذه
الممارسات الغربيه بانها محاوله لتطويق
الصين
طبعا يعني هذا خطوات يعني واضحه لمواجهه
لاحتواء الصين
والصين
تدعو مرارا وتكرارا على الى عدم
التشكيل او عدم العوده الى فكره الحرب
البارده وترى سين انها بمنطقه اسيا
والباسفيك هي منطقه اكثر حيويه اكثر حيويه
لها اكبر امكانيه التي تتهور
وتنميه اقتصاديه فلذلك
تطلب دائما من احد الدول الثلاثه السحب
هذا التعاون
لاحترام التتابعات الشعوب واحترام القانون
الدولي وكذلك يعني ليساهم في السلام
واستقرار في هذه المنطقه والادم تحويلها
الى يعني من طاقه للمجابهات او منافسات
الجيول سياسيه
ستدفع استراليا الان الى مواجهه ربما مع
الصين ام انه لا تنظرون الى كل دوله على
حده ولكن الى هذا التجمع بشكل كامل او هذه
القوه
طبعا هناك زياده لهذا الخطر يعني خطر
مواجهه
ولكن الصين
تبادر الى اي مواجهه مع احد الدول
ستبدو الاقصى جهودها للحفاظ على السلام
والاستقرار في هذا المنطقه والحفاظ ايضا
على التوازن الاستراتيجي لكي لا يشون اي
حربا من الدول الاخرى على الصين شكرا
جزيلا لك اذا من بكين الصحفي نادرونج
شكرا شكرا لكم
نشرتنا مستمره فيها بعض الفاصل مسؤولون
اسرائيليون يؤكدون ان ايران تنشروا
رادارات بسوريا للانذار عن اي هجوم محتمل
اهلا بكم من جديد تشهد الاسواق الاسيويه
موجوده تراجعات كبرى في بورصات اليابان
وكوريا الجنوبيه وهونج كونج وتراجع مؤشر
نيكاي الياباني تراجع بنحو 600 نقطه باكثر
من 2.5 كم انخفض مؤشر كوسبي في كوريا
الجنوبيه بنحو 2% بسبب مخاوف المستثمرين
تزامنا مع ازمه البنوك الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
اذا تداعيات انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي ادت
الى استمراري خسائر اسهم البنوك العالميه
صباح الثلاثاء رغم محاولات رئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن وغيره من المسؤولين لتهدئه هذه
الاسواق كما انخفضت اسعار النفط اليوم
مواصله خسائرها للجلسه الثانيه اذ ادى
انهيار بنك السيليكون فالي الى هزه في
اسواق الاسهم واثار مخاوف من وقوع ازمه
ماليه جديده كما يجتمع وزراء ماليه اوروبا
في بروكسل والملف هذا الملف على الطاوله
نشات اخرى قال الرئيس التنفيذي لبنك
سيليكون فالي انه بامكان المودعين الوصول
بحريه لاموالهم وان الودائع محميه مؤكدا
ان الاداره البنك تسير الاعمال التجاريه
كالمعتاد داخل الولايات المتحده وتوقع
الرئيس التنفيذي لبنك سيليكون فالي
استئناف المعاملات عبر الحدود في الايام
المقبله
اجراءات عده اتخذتها وزاره الخزانه
الامريكيه بالتشاوري مع الرئيس جو بايدن
ومع البنك الاحتياطي الفيدرالي لتجنب
تداعيات انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي ولتمكين
المودعين من الحصول على اموالهم ان الله
اكرر لا خسائر سيتحملها دافع والضرائب من
اهم ما اكد عليه الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
خلال كلمته هو ان جميع اموال المودعين ود
افعين مؤمنه ويمكن الحصول عليها من دون
عائق وطلب من الامريكيين الثقه في النظام
المصرفي فقبل هذه الازمه كانت الحكومه
الفيدراليه تضمن من خلال المؤسسه
الفيدراليه للتامين على الودائع الودائع
التي لا تزيد قيمتها عن 250 الف دولار
قاعده 250 الف دولار ستستمر ولن تتراجع
الحكومه عنها السبب الوحيد لتعليقها
للبنكين منع العدو الماليه لكن الحكومه
ستغير بعض اللوائح في المستقبل لمحاوله
الحد من اي خطر معنوي ربما يكون قد تسببوا
فيه عبر اقتراح ان الحكومه ستتدخل دائما
لانقاذ المودعين لكن الوضع بالنسبه
للمستثمرين الذين يخاطرون بودائع امريكيين
مختلف وفق بايدن لانهم لن يحظوا باي حمايه
فيما تعهد بمحاسبه المسؤولين عن ازمه
البنوك معتبرا ان لا احد فوق القانون
سيتم طرد اداره هذه البنوك اذا تم
الاستيلاء على البنك من قبل المؤسسه
الفيدراليه للتامين على الودائع فيجب على
الاشخاص الذين يديرون البنك الا يعملوا
هناك بعد الان
بيضا وعد بان الاجراءات لحمايه المودعين
ولعدم تكرار اخفاقات البنوك ستستمر الى ان
تنتهي ازمه مصرفي سيليكون
فيما سيطلب من الكونجرس تجديد القوانين
المتعلقه بالبنوك
العربيه واشنطن ننتقل مباشره الى موسكو
كلمه لوزير الخارجيه الروسيه حتى يحرمون
اسر
من
زيرو من شكلها الطبيعي وبما في ذلك يحولون
شيطنات روسيا واتهام روسيا في
كل ذنب
انطلاقا من التصرفات
الانانيه والاستعماريه من قبل الغرب في
بدايه الجائحه الكورونا
عندما اشتروا
المواد الغذائيه بكميه ضخمه من العالميه
ويتهمون في ذلك
وهذا سبب في
ازمه الغدائيه
رغم ذلك يحولون اتهام روسيا في ذلك
ويتهمون روسيا في
المعاصي
التي
يمر بها المجتمع العروبي على خلفيه
ارتفاعه
اسعار الطاقه وسعر النفط يتهمون روسيا في
ذلك ويحملوننا على مسؤوليه عن ذلك ورسوله
هي قالت
رئيس بايدن شكرا لديكم على
انكم
سعدتم في التخلص من الموارد الطاقه
الروسيه
في نفس الوقت
اوروبا مضطره لشراء المواضيع مواد الطاقه
من امريكا
اسعار مضاعفه
لهذا سيكون هناك
اواقف وخيمه
ويؤثر ذلك على قدره اوروبا للتنافس في
الاسواق العالميه وعلينا ان ندرك
قيمه
لروسيا
على الذي
بدر بها
السيد مالينا
ويحافظون يحافظ عليها
الى حب ليس في اننا نحول مواجهه
الغرب
والقيم
[موسيقى]
القائمين بالعملات الصليبيه
في ذلك
يقولون
روسيا
تسعى
اراد
الاحاريين
للناس الا ذلك نحن ندافع عن مصالحنا
وندافع عن
شعور
بالعداله
للشعب الروسي
من هذا الشعور
بالعداله انظر الى مبادره
واصدقائه من دعموا هذه المبادره
ولا اود ان اتحدث بالتفاصيل عن
[موسيقى]
امثله الكراهيه لروسيا
الفظيعه
التي نراها في دوله الغربيه في اوروبا في
استراليا
[موسيقى]
دول اخرى
من خلال
انشاء على هياكل الكتله مثل او كوس
ومن خلال ذلك
يهددون بالصدام و بالمواجهه المباشره على
السنوات طويله
لا اتخيل كيف
تخشع الدول الاسيويه
لايرادات واشنطن واملاءاتها
وايرادات الدول لاندوسكس
عنايعتكم الى
[موسيقى]
ظبط
الفرق الاساسي
بين
مؤتمرنا بين المجموعات التي يجمعها
الاهارب في كل انحاء العالم
من
التواصل مع روسيا ومن افريقيا
والاتفاقات مع روسيا
وفيما يخص البيان معتمرنا
[موسيقى]
اهدافنا وهذا الاهداف في تعزيز التعاون
والصداقه
والشراكه
وهذا يميز
الحضاره الروسيه والحضاره الصينيه الحضاره
الهنديه والعربيه
[موسيقى]
مثل ما كان في
جورجيا
مؤخرا
يقولون ان كل ذلك
المغامرات الروسيه ولا اشكركم انهم
يبداون الحملات المضاده
لحركاتنا
الظروف علينا ان نلتزم بالصداقه
الذي قال بان روسيا تدافع عن مصالحها ولا
تنشر
التهديدات
ونعود الى ملفنا لليوم الذي هو عن انهيار
بنك سيليكون وينضم الينا حول هذا الموضوع
من باريس استاذ جامعي وباحث في العلوم
الماليه الاقتصاديه الدكتور حسن عبيد اهلا
بك دكتور حسن يعني لماذا يمتد التاثير
السلبي لانهيار هذا المصرف الامريكي على
باقي الاسواق العالميه والبنوك الاخرى
نعم شكرا للاستضافه بطبيعه الحال عندما
يصبح هناك اي ازمه في القطاع المصرفي
بالتحديد وفي القطاع المالي بشكل عام فمن
الطبيعه الامر ان يكون المستثمر على حذر
من تداعيات هذا الامر فلذلك فهو يتجه نحو
القطاعات الاكثر امنا وبالتالي تؤدي الى
انخفاض في يعني مؤشرات الاسواق في
القطاع الذي يمتد عبره هذا القطاع فالقطاع
المصرفي بالتحديد فاذا هي موضوع متعلق
بثقه المستثمر هذا هو بالتحديد الذي يؤدي
الى
انهاء او الى التاثيرات الموضوع الاخر هو
كان هناك شبكه بين نعم ولكن يعني اعطى
التطمينات
كبيره للمستثمرين وايضا للمذيعين لماذا لم
تطمئنهم
طبعا الرئيس الامريكي هناك تطمينات يعني
سياسيه التقنيات اعلاميه وتطمينات ماليه
التطمينات السياسيه ظهرت من الرئيس
الامريكي لا يمكن التعويل عليها كثيرا اذا
لم تترافق مع اليات واضحه وشفافه ومن
الفيدرالي
الامريكي عندما قال الفيدرالي الامريكي ان
الامر اننا سنتدخل لحل هذه المعضله لذلك
وجدنا مثلا ان الاسواق ارتاحت قليلا لم
تزل تتاثر ولكنها
بوتيره اقل ففي اوروبا مثلا نحن نشهد
اليوم انخفاض في اليورونيكس ولكن بوتيره
اقل من ما كانت عليه نهايه الاسبوع الماضي
وبدايه الاسبوع واليوم يعني صباح اليوم
الساعه 9:00 الصبح عندما فتحت فاذا هناك
تطمينات لابد من
من المؤسسات الماليه فكل الكلام السياسي
الذي يصدر عنه المؤسسات السياسيه لا يمكن
الاخذ به اذا لم يكن يترافق بتطمنات ماليه
هذا امر الامر الاخر
يعني بالحقيقه
يعني مشكله او ازمه
السيليكون فالي بنك هي يمكن ان اطمئن يعني
كمحلل اقتصادي ومحلل مالي ومختص بالعلوم
المصرفيه انها لم لن تمتد ولن تمتد كما
حصل في البنك
2007 لعده امور يعني امر واضح منها هي ان
حجم سيليكون فالي هو 210 مليار حجم حجم لا
من برازر كان 600 مليار فهناك فرق في
الحجم وهناك فرق ايضا في
المحفظه الاوراق وفي تشكيل الميزانيه
للمصرفين بين سيليكون فالي وبينز شكرا
جزيلا لك اذا من باريس الدكتور حسن عباد
الباحث في العلوم الماليه والاقتصاديه
في البدايه كنت خائفا لكنني كنت اعرف انني
مؤمن لذلك سمعت انه من المؤكد انني ساسترد
اموالي ثم بدات في قراءه المقالات على
الانترنت وسمعت تصريح وزيره الخزانه ان
البنك سيفتتح يوم الاثنين
اشعر بالتفاؤل الان حول عمليه نقل جميع
الحسابات والاموال
لقد انجزنا جميع مهامنا الائتمانيه تاثرنا
بشكل ضئيل جدا ولم يكن لدينا اي مشكله من
حيث كشوف الرواتب ولكن ما تزال هناك ضغوط
كثيره
اوضح مسؤولون في الامن الاسرائيلي لموقع
والا في تل ابيب ان ايران تنشر شبكه
رادارات الانذار في سوريا لتحمي مواقعها
النوويه تحسبا من اي هجوم اسرائيلي محتمل
هذا وتنصب طهران بحسب المسؤولين بطاريات
صواريخ ارض جو حتى تشكل ذراعا مكتمل
الجاهزيه لصد اي هجوم ونقلا عن والا فان
الايرانيين بداوا يتفهمون ان رؤيه قائد
فيلق القدس بالحرس الثوري قاسم سليماني
باقامه قاعده عسكريه وتركيز على الاراضي
السوريه لن تدخل حيز التنفيذ وذلك بسبب
شكل اساسي بسبب انشطه الجيش الاسرائيلي
بعد اصدار مذكره اعتقال جديده ضد رئيس
الوزراء الباكستانيه السابق عمران بسبب
تهديد تهديد قاضيه انتقد عمران خان
الحكومه واتهامها باستخدام وسائل عده
الاجباره على الانسحاب من الانتخابات وتعد
الحكومه بمسيره احتجاجيه حاشده ضد
انتهاكاتها ضده
مجرم هذا البلد من الحكومه يستخدمون كل
تكتيك ممكن لاجبارنا على الخروج من
الانتخابات ولذلك هم يرفعون القضايا ضدي
وسنعقد مسيره احتجاجيه الاحد المقبل
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل رئيسه
وزراء بريطانيا السابقه تفتح مخزن اسرارها
وتتحدث عن اساءه استخدام السلطه
اهلا بكم من جديد بدات المصارف اللبنانيه
في اضراب مفتوح احتجاجا على الملاحقات
القضائيه واقتصار العملات البنكيه على
الصراف الاليه بحيث ان معظم التحويلات
وصرف الرواتب سيتم خارج المصارف ويبدا
الاضراب على وقع اقتراب سعر صرف الدولار
من سقف المئه الف ليره للدولار الواحد في
السوق السوداء في ارتفاعا غير مسبوق
وقياسي منذلاع الازمه الماليه اواخر عام
2019 وتبعا بهذا الارتفاع وارتفاعات
مماثله في اسعار المواد الاساسيه حيث قارب
سعر صفيحه البنزين مليون تقريبا مليونين
يعني واحد فاصل ثمانيه مليون ليره تحديدا
اضافه لارتفاع اسعار المواد الاوليه
الاخرى موضوع اخر اعلنا الجيش الكوري
الجنوبي ان كوريا الشماليه اطلقت صاروخين
بالستيين قاسيري المدى من اقليم هانجاي
الجنوبي قرب الساحل الغربي للبلاد وقلت
هيئه الاركان المشتركه الكوريه الجنوبيه
الى الجيش على درجه تاهب عاليه وفي وضع
الجاهزيه الكامله بتنسيق وثيق مع الولايات
المتحده ياتي ذلك غادات انطلاق مناورات
عسكريه امريكيه كوريا الجنوبيه مشتركه هي
الاوسع نطاقا منذ خمس سنوات
ووصف رئيس الوزراء الياباني اطلاق كوريا
الشماليه لصاروخين تجاه بحر اليابان بانه
اجراء استفزازيون وهناك احتماليه لتكرار
كما ذكرنا في السابق نعتقد ان هناك
احتمالا بان تساعد كوريا الشماليه المزيد
من الاجراءات الاستفزازيه بما في ذلك
اطلاق الصواريخ واجراء التجارب النوويه
قلع الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
ان اعاده انتخابه فقط كرئيس للولايات
المتحده في عام 2024 ستنقذ البلاد من خطر
اندلاع الحرب العالميه الثالثه واضاف
ترامب خلال مؤتمر انتخابي انه يعتقد بشده
في اندلاع حرب عالميه ثالثه مهاجما اداره
جو بايدن التي اكد انها لا ترسل الاشارات
الصحيحه ولا تعرف ما يجب فعله لمنع
المخاطر
اعلنت دار هيد لاين للنشر ان رئيسه
الوزراء البريطانيه السابقه تيريزاماي
ستصدر كتابا بعنوان اساءه استخدام السلطه
بحلول شهر سبتمبر المقبل ووفق دار النشر
ستفصح ماي عن ارائها حول الحاجه الى
اصلاحات سياسيه في بلادها بعد ان واجهت
سلسله من القضايا التي ادت الى فقدان ثقه
الافراد في السياسيين داعيه الى استخدام
القوه من اجل الصالح العام وكمثال على هذه
الاحداث استشهدت دار النشر بالحريق الذي
انزل على المبنى السكني في عام 2017 مبنى
جرين فل والذي اودى بحياه 71 شخصا
اظهرت لقطات من طائره مسيره فوق مقاطعه
الوسط ولايه كاليفورنيا الامريكيه مجتمعا
غمرته المياه باكمله بعد فشل السد في نهر
باشر
[موسيقى]
نهايه النشره تذكير بابرز العناوين
موسكو وكاف تخوضاني معارك عنيفه للسيطره
على وسط بحمط والجنائيه الدوليه تلاحق
مسؤولين روس
ازمه بنك سيليكون فالي تطالب اسيا ووزراء
ماليه اوروبا يجتمعون في بروكسل والملف
حاضرا على الطاوله
صفقه امريكيه بريطانيه لتزويد استراليا
بغواصات نوويه والصين تدعو للتخلي عن
عقليه الحرب البارده
تطلق صاروخين باليسيين باتجاه بحر اليابان
وسط تدريبات عسكريه امريكيه كوريا
الجنوبيه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]